شوارع الخرطوم شبه خاليه لا امن ولا امان
اما اسواقها يكبل الكساد ايدي التجار فيها
فالمعروض قليل والطلب شبه معدومه
اقتصاد السودان صعد على سكه خسائر لا يمكن
التصور ابعادها وبات شبح المجاعه يهدد كل
من تقطعت بهم سبل الخروج منه برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي وصف الوضع الانساني في
البلاد بالكارثي مؤكدا انه يجب ان يتوقف
القتال اولا لتمكين ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه بامان
وضع انساني يزداد كل يوم سوءا وتحيط به
مخاوف من ارتفاع جنني في اسعار المواد
الغذائيه والوقود معنى فادي الاموال
والامدادات الاساسيه وتعطل الانظمه
المصرفيه
حالهم بات غايه في السوق والتردي واصعب
مهامهم تامين قوتهم اليومي وحاجاتهم
الغذائيه حيث شهدت اسعار السلع
الاستهلاكيه الضروريه في العاصمه الخرطوم
ارتفاعا كبيرا ومفاجئا مع اعتبره
السودانيون غير مبرر في حين عزاه البعض
الى استغلال التجار لظروف المواطنين
الصعبه
اندلاع الحرب جدد المخاوف من انزلاق
الاقتصاد السوداني نحو الانهيار الشامل
فمع دخول الحرب الاسبوع الثالث واستمرار
عمليات الاجلاء سترتفع احتمالات اصابه
النشاط الاقتصادي بالشلل وستنجر البلاد
نحو مصير مظلم واكبر خطرا
اياد حمود العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوث
ائقيانسو للاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات